[Music]
from Tiana to Moana Disney artists have
made it their mission to develop more
princesses from different cultures and
ethnicities even though they are
beautiful just the way they are we can't
get enough of these beautiful photos of
Disney Princesses as different races if
you're new to our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up because today we'll be
sharing 10 alternate stories of Disney
Princesses in other countries part 2
just wait until you see the new version
of Elsa we guarantee you'll be amazed
Anna this picture depicts the way we all
know and love Princess Anna the frozen
character captured our hearts when the
2013 film was released with her bubbly
personality her turquoise blue eyes and
her strawberry blonde hair she's
definitely perfect in our eyes even
though Anna is beautiful just the way
she is we just can't get enough of
artist t.t Brett's recreation courtesy
of the blog let there be doodles Anna is
reimagined into an inuit woman this
group of indigenous people inhabits the
icy cold arctic regions of Canada
Denmark Russia and the United States as
an Inuit Anna wears layers of heavy
clothing including a winter coat trimmed
in fur and mittens to protect her from
the chilly weather her freckles are
completely gone and her two long braids
as well as her eyes are much darker in
color and his appearance mimics the tan
skin of the Inuits and looking at her
new appearance really makes us crave in
eskimo disney princess would you watch a
recreation of frozen with inuit
characters like the one in this picture
let us know in the comments section down
below rapunzel rapunzel is well known as
the disney princess with the magical
hair that stretches beyond belief
her entire look is completely
mesmerizing aside from her golden blonde
hair she has captivating green eyes
dainty brown freckles and large brown
eyelashes she's definitely one of the
most beautiful Disney Princesses we've
ever seen but artist et Brett made her
even more lovely with this fantastic
piece of art the German princesses fair
skin light hair and eyes are altered to
turn her into a gorgeous Mexican beauty
in this photo Rapunzel's hair is much
darker and her eye colour is changed
dark brown she still has the same
features but she's sporting some pretty
jewelry just check out her gold earrings
she also wears even more
flowers all throughout her hair
including roses and Dahlia Panetta's the
Dahlia is the national flower of Mexico
and it originates from the mountainous
regions to complete Rapunzel's
transformation into a Mexican princess
she wears an embroidered peasant blouse
which is customary attire in Mexican
culture
if tangled took place in Mexico instead
of the fictional kingdom of Corona how
different do you think the movie would
have been Arielle New York resident
Brian Flynn wanted to do something
memorable for his girlfriend Mohini
Gupta on Valentine's Day he reached out
to his friend and artist Dylan Bonner
and asked him for a huge favor Mohini is
a big Disney fan so he thought it would
only be right to have her recreated as a
few of her favorite Disney Princesses
Dylan gladly took on the task and the
results are breathtaking Dylan put his
creativity to work and recreated mini-me
as Ariel from The Little Mermaid just
take a look at the finished product she
now sports a head full of dark hair and
huge brown eyes her fair skin is also a
bit more tend to match minimis
complexion seeing Ariel look completely
different from the way she first
appeared in the 1989 film takes some
getting used to but we're falling in
love with her new look do you think
Ariel looks better before or after she
was recreated as an Indian mermaid we
would love to hear what you think a long
way Ilyn wheeze the talkative and young
beauty from the Black Cauldron the
princess looks a lot like many of the
more popular characters in the Disney
Princess lineup she has long blonde hair
that she tames with the violet headband
pink lips and beautiful blue eyes but
are you ready to see what she looks like
now go ahead and take a look at the new
version of a long way the Disney
Princesses Central European features are
altered to turn her into a Fulani woman
the Fulani people are the largest Muslim
ethnic group in Sahel and West Africa
their lives are enriched by their deep
cultural traditions when their small
children the Fulani men and women both
receive tribal markings around their
eyes and mouths in the artist drawing of
villain we she sports those same
markings on her face she also wears a
head covering gold hoop earrings a gold
necklace and gold bangles on her wrists
this is such a beautiful recreation
don't you agree how amazing would it be
of Disney revamped the Black Cauldron
and other films to depict African
characters like the revamped Fulani
version of
we Jane Porter Jane Porter of the 1999
film Tarzan is a gorgeous young woman
living in Victorian era Britain the
smart and curious woman is known for her
wispy brown hair and her dazzling blue
eyes but have you ever wondered what
Jane would look like if she were from a
different country
well artist titi Bret has answered your
wishes check out this awesome recreation
of the Disney character as a Korean
woman her hair and eyes are noticeably
much darker and the shape of her eyes
has completely changed her lips are a
bit fuller and her skin is fairer as a
Korean princess Jane's hair is styled in
a braided bun decorated with tiny
delicate flowers as far as her clothing
goes she ditches her tan and green
outfit for pieces that represent Korea's
heritage and culture as you can see
she's wearing a geo gory which is a long
jacket that's worn with a handbag would
you be interested in watching a Korean
version of the film Tarzan we would love
to know what you think Elsa I also
became one of the most popular Disney
characters when frozen was released in
2013
many people are drawn to her because of
her good looks especially her beautiful
platinum blonde hair her rosy cheeks and
her blue eyes but artist Juliet J m15
noticed Disney fans were craving more
representation and diversity in the
princess lineup instead of waiting for
animators to listen to fans concerns the
artists took matters into her own hands
she thought it would be so cool to see
Elsa as a completely different race
so she revamp the ice queen from head to
toe and now she's almost unrecognizable
take a look at this picture the artist
has turned Elsa into an african-american
woman and now we see the character in a
whole new light her hair is now brown
and wavy and her skin is golden brown
her features have also completely
changed and the new Elsa has much fuller
lips and piercing brown eyes this race
spent version of the Disney Princess
makes her jaws drop do you think it
would be a good idea to re-release
frozen with an african-american
character playing the role of Elsa
Esmeralda we all became enchanted by
Esmeralda in 1996 Disney film The
Hunchback of Notre Dom the Romani woman
resides in Paris and she has a very
unique look with distinctive features
her green eyes glow brightly and she can
put anyone in a trend to top it off no
other Disney character has better hair
than her we didn't think it was possible
for Esmeralda to get more
but we were wrong take a look at the
artist tt Bret's rendition of her as a
beautiful Moroccan woman her shimmery
green eyes have been replaced with a
golden brown color and her entire
wardrobe is altered she now wears the
traditional clothing that represents the
country's rich history and traditions
her teal nude and tan caftan really
brings out the color of her skin and how
beautiful is her head where it's a piece
of embroidered cloth that is worn with
one end draped over the left shoulder if
Disney ever has plans to re-release The
Hunchback of Notre Dom with a lineup of
Moroccan characters they should
definitely use this drawing of Esmeralda
for some inspiration Pocahontas when the
animated film Pocahontas was released in
1995 the world rejoiced when they saw
images of the Native American princess
she offered some much-needed diversity
to the Disney Princess lineup the
character has the physical
characteristics that are associated with
natives
she is sunkissed skin high cheekbones
and long dark hair to go along with her
dark features but can you imagine if the
story of Pocahontas was completely
recreated instead of being Native
American this artist decided to convert
the free-spirited character into a
European Princess Pocahontas his hair is
now light brown to match her brown eyes
and her nose a sharp and slender it
really doesn't matter which race
Pocahontas becomes because one thing
always stays the same her fabulous head
full of gorgeous hair this drawing just
proves that all Disney Princesses are
beautiful no matter their race culture
or heritage fans fall in love with each
princess because of who they are on the
inside not because of the way they look
on the outside what do you think about
this new version of Pocahontas let us
know your thoughts down below in the
comment section Mulan in 1998 Disney
surprised us all by unveiling their
brand-new Chinese princess mulan is the
toughest nails fighting warrior who's
known for her bravery and heroism when
it comes to her looks Disney animators
stuck to traditional Chinese physical
characteristics from her butt nose to
her wide eyes and dark hair we love the
way Mulan looks already and we wouldn't
change a thing about her artist titi
Bret decided to give her a bit of a
cultural makeover we have to say his
drawing really catches us off-guard
because we weren't expecting to see the
warrior princess look quite like this
Mulan is now a Native American princess
and we can't take her eyes off of her
for long dark hair is styled into two
braids she even has
feather sticking out from the side of
her head and feather earrings dangling
from her ears her skin is more ten and
her cheeks are even rosier than before
now check out the rest of her jewelry
how beautiful are her necklaces in
choker it really reminds us of
traditional native jewelry are you
captivated by the new version of Mulan
as much as we are Merida in 2012 Disney
introduced its very first Scottish
Princess Merida in the movie brave
Merida is the headstrong princess of
dunbroch who holds on tight to her bow
and arrow when you think of the
character Merida you probably think of
her wild and untamed red hair her blue
eyes and her dark teal outfit but wait
until you see what she looks like now in
the blink of an eye the old Merida is
gone and she's transformed into a
Brazilian princess isn't the artist
recreation amazing it doesn't even look
like the same character anymore she
still has the same curly and frizzy hair
but it's no longer red like before
Merida now has dark curly locks that she
secures with a fashionable red headband
and she wears an off-the-shoulder blue
blouse her light freckles have also been
replaced with gold and bronze skin and
just take a look at her once blue eyes
they're now hazel what do you think of
this new version of Merida do you think
now's the time for Disney to release a
new princess that originates from Brazil
we think so which of these cultural
makeovers of Disney Princesses did you
love the most
let us know in the comments section and
the most original reply will be pinned
to our channel if you'd like to see more
videos like this don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]